Heute im Rasenfunk?
Blick auf andere Jungen. Was viele nicht wissen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, da draußen ist, das war jetzt gar nicht das eigentliche Intro, sondern das waren wir, die das live eingesprochen haben, denn so enthusiastisch sind wir heute morgen in der Liga Tour und damit Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost und hier begrüße ich bei mir zum einen Fabian Pakulat. Hallo Fabian. Mario Rieker, hi Mario. Und Uli Hebel. Servus Uli. Ja, wir sind absolut hyped. So kann man das glaube ich sagen, das war hier ein wahrer Rave, bevor wir losgelegt haben. Aber gut, es ist für uns alle sehr früh und viele von uns haben auch noch nachts gearbeitet. Das ist keine gute Kombination, aber für euch machen wir das natürlich trotzdem und das alles, obwohl der Rasenfunk reinspendenfinanziert ist oder vielleicht gerade weil er reinspendenfinanziert ist. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub, da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann und bitte tut das auch und empfehlt gerne auch diese Sendung weiter. Und dann würde ich sagen, gar nicht lange drum rum schnacken, sondern wir legen direkt los. Wir wollen heute ein bisschen sprechen über La Liga, die Serie A und die Premier League. Die Ligue 1 hat es leider nicht geschafft. Die war zu motiviert. Unsere League-R-Experten waren alle zu hype. Da haben wir gesagt, das überlastet diese Sendung. Hoffentlich schaffen wir es wieder zum nächsten Mal. Aber diesmal war es nicht möglich. Und jetzt ist die große Frage, wo wir loslegen. Ich glaube, wir beginnen in Spanien, denn Fabian ist schon am längsten hier im Call, hat schon am meisten von seinem Enthusiasmus versprüht. Und jetzt darfst du uns direkt drüber retten. Auch du hast wieder zwei Themen mitgebracht, Fabian. Such dir aus, mit was du beginnst.
Jetzt muss er nur noch ein Tor schießen, das hat er glaube ich noch nicht geschafft in der Premier League, oder? Habe ich das übersehen? Ich glaube, er schiebt noch ein Tor.
Das glaube ich nicht. Die haben allgemein nicht so ganz viele Tore, sondern das läuft eher über ein aggressives Gegenarbeiten. Aber ich, also Looten, hätte ich nie gedacht, dass die, die werden nicht kampflos runtergehen. Lass das mal sicher.
Stark. Peli Rodak Mpanzo. Wer bei YouTube zugeguckt hat, der hat gesehen, wie ich in der Sekunde panisch einen Tab geöffnet habe. Und sehr dankbar war, als du gesagt hast, Looten. Ah, okay, dann wusste ich auch, wo ich suchen muss. Hatte ich nicht auf dem Schirm. Fabian, wen habe ich denn in La Liga nicht auf dem Schirm?
Ein Ansanchiro, oder? Genau, dann waren wir noch bei baskischen Trainer, dann habe ich auch ein Gegenbeispiel, ein schönes, nämlich Galska Caritano, der hat vor ein paar Spieltagen Almeria übernommen und hat bisher noch nichts gerissen. War ein interessanter Trainer eigentlich. War Spieler übrigens auch von San Sebastian, hat dann Ewa ziemlich stark trainiert in der zweiten, aber auch in der ersten Liga. Hat danach auch mal Athletic Bilbao bekommen als Trainerstation, da hat er das aber auch nicht gerissen. Und jetzt hat er mal wieder einen Job bekommen in Almeria und da läuft es auch nicht so gut. Also ich glaube, bei dem geht es wirklich steil bergab, was die Trainerkarriere anbelangt.
Also am Anfang aber auch kein Hero, habe ich das gerade richtig verstanden. Rightfully Neglected.
Ein Unsung Anti-Hero sozusagen.
Man wird hier doch immer wieder überrascht.
Bayer, was hast du uns mitgebracht? Ein Spieler, der im Sommer von Donatskas Treda, dem ehemaligen Verein von Peter Hibala, Tomislav Maric, Werner Lorand und Bernd Stork, das weil ich es einfach getrobbt habe, nach Italien gekommen ist. Nikola Kristović, Stürmer der montenecrinischen Nationalmannschaft, 23 Jahre jung, spielt bei Lecce, die ja tatsächlich als auch mit den Aufstärkern als Abstiegskandidat Nummer 1 gehandelt wurden, die sich jetzt nach einem sehr guten Saisonstart auch wieder um jetzt ein paar Linerlagen aber gefangen haben. Spielstarker, Beidfüßiger, Stürmer, 4 Tore schon gemacht in 8 Partien und das bei einem Verein wie Lecce also mit dafür verantwortlich, dass die aktuell überhaupt gar keine Abstiegssorgen haben.
Christovic, weiß man, ob der dann auch, war das nicht bei Serbien, Montenegro so? Ach Gott, wie heißt die Legende? Ne, ach ich hab's gerade mit Nordmazedonien verwechselt. Sorry, vergesst alles, was ich sage.
Er hat jetzt aber gegen Serbien gespielt, auf jeden Fall, da haben sie verloren.
Jaja, genau, ich hatte es gerade, weil sein Name war mir über den Weg gelaufen. Ja, ich hab's gerade aber völlig, diese Abzweigung war falsch, aber ich hab's ja noch gemerkt. Deswegen, Moment des Spieltags oder der Woche, Mario, das gleich weitermachen.
Ja, dann mach ich nochmal kurz den Bogen zu unserem ersten Thema. Der Moment der Woche war Stefan El-Sharawi, der den vierten Pflichtspiel-Sieg für die Roma mit einem 1-0-Sieg-Treffer in der 90. Minute gegen Monza eingetütet hat und nach dem Spiel dann in, oder direkt im Anschluss in Tränen ausgebrochen ist, denn auch er war einer, der stand jetzt zu Unrecht beschuldigt wurde und der in den letzten Wochen auch viel Druck aushalten musste rund um die Wettgeschichte. Also das war schön, aber auch traurig zu sehen. Das war beides. Das waren Tränen der Erleichterung und, oder, aber auf jeden Fall ein Moment, so der halt eben auf dem Sportplatz dann geparkt mit viel Emotionen entsteht.
Ja, absolut. Fabian, welchen Moment möchtest du uns noch mitgeben? Oder hast du einen Anti-Moment mitgebracht? Die 37.
Es gibt in Spanien eine ziemlich gute Fernsehsendung, die immer den Spieltag beleuchtet. El día después, der Tag danach heißt die. Und die machen immer ziemlich schöne Geschichten. Und da ist mir diese Woche eine sehr schöne Geschichte aufgefallen. Und zwar ist dort in Osasuna war das, in einem Heimspiel, das erste Mal Vater und Tochter zusammen ins Stadion gegangen. Die Tochter war da wohl schon öfter der Vater das erste Mal, denn der ist nämlich blind gewesen. Und dann hat die Kamera darauf gehalten, wie die beiden das Spiel zusammen verfolgen. Und der Vater ist auch großer Osasuna-Fan, aber man kann es natürlich nicht sehen. Die Tochter hat ihm dann immer ein bisschen erklärt, wie es gerade so läuft. Das war wohl auch ziemlich spannend. Osasuna hat das Ding dann noch gewonnen. Und beide waren wohl ziemliche Fans von Jimmy Avila. Und dann hat die Tochter gesagt, jetzt läuft der Jimmy hier direkt bei uns vorbei. Und da ist er und so weiter. Und er so, wow. Und das war sehr emotional, das Ganze. Und ja, es war einfach ein schöner Moment, wie man da so zwei Personen gesehen hat, die zusammen Fußball genießen, obwohl der eine ja eigentlich nicht sehen kann. Aber er hat die Emotionen im Stadion mitgenommen und er war natürlich dementsprechend auch gerührt. Und es gab da noch einen schönen Nachdreh. Denn Jimmy Avila hat es gesehen, den Bericht wohl anscheinend und sucht jetzt die beiden und möchte sich mit denen treffen. Und das hat zwar noch nicht stattgefunden, aber ich bin mir sicher, da gibt es noch ein richtig schönes Happy End. Gute Frage, kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Aber ein sehr schöner Moment des Spieltags. Und das knüpft auch an eine Power-Hörerin, deren Lieblingsformat ist. Ganz herzliche Grüße an Pina. Sie liebt die Ligatur. Die Ligatur ist die einzige Folge vom Rasenfunk, die sie immer in der Chronologie vorzieht. Ansonsten hört sie alles vom Rasenfunk chronologisch. Und wir haben mit Pina mal ein Tribüngespräch gemacht, wie es ist, als Blinde im Fußballstadion zu sein, weil sie schon seit den 80ern in deutschen Fußballstadien, in Unterhaching, im Olympiastadion und so weiter unterwegs war. Und da gab es logischerweise noch keinen Kommentar für Menschen, die nicht sehen können. Und da hat sie einfach zum Teil Leute angesprochen, hat gesagt, hier erzähl mir mal, was passiert. Total faszinierend, werde ich verlinken. War ein sehr schönes Tribüngespräch. Pina, herzliche Grüße an der Stelle. Hätte ich auch nicht gedacht, dass wir das an der Stelle hier nur machen.
Bin mir aber sicher, dass es das gibt, eigentlich in Spanien, wo ich drüber nachdenke, es gibt auch Fußball-Kommentate für, na wie sagt man, für Hörgeschädigte, wo dann in Gebär... Entschuldigung, ich weiß nicht, wie man es nennt. Das Ganze kommentiert wird und allgemein ist Spanien sehr behindertenfreundlich, wenn ich das so sagen darf. Die machen ziemlich viele gute Sachen. Und ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass es dann auch für blinde Fußball-Kommentare gibt.
In Sicherheit.
Sehr gut. Mensch, was wir hier immer noch für Themen mitmachen. Ich mag die Ligatur auch. So, jetzt wird uns Uli noch rauswerfen mit seinem Moment.
Ja, das tue ich wirklich, weil ich die Stimmung ein wenig drücke. Ich leime mir mal einen Moment aus der Champions League aus. Und der wird dann auch sicherlich übergehen, aber ins nächste Wochenende. Sir Bobby Charlton ist verstorben. Am Samstag. Die Nachricht kam im Verlauf des Spieltags, kurz vor dem Manchester City Spiel. Da ist dann schon gedacht worden. Also improvisiert sozusagen. Was dann auch nochmal zeigt, wie landesübergreifend Sir Bobby Charlton gewirkt hat. Also das kann man sich hier gar nicht vorstellen in Deutschland. Wie wichtig der für den englischen Fußball war als Weltmeister 66, als Überlebender des Flugzeugabsturzes von 58 über München, als dann spätere Europapokalsieger, also originales Busby Babe und dann auch zum Sir geworden, einer der großen Gentlemans des Sports. Und diese Schweigeminuten in der Champions League am Mittwoch in Manchester und sämtliche Kommentare aus der gesamten Fußballwelt, die nochmal einfach klar gemacht haben, wie wichtig dieser Mann, dieser Fußballspieler war und ist und bleiben wird, die fand ich sehr ergreifend. Das ist etwas, das in England einfach besser funktioniert als hier in Deutschland, finde ich. Der Umgang mit den wirklich Großen in dem Sport. Und ich bin sehr gespannt. Am Wochenende steht es Manchester Dabian. Was da passieren wird, ist irgendwie tragisch schön, dass dieses Manchester Dabie das erste Heimspiel nach seinem Ableben dann in der Premier League genau da hinfällt und dass das noch mal so wirkt, als wäre es eine Celebration seines gesamten Lebens. Also großen Respekt vor Sir Bobby Chiton, auch einer der ersten Namen, logischerweise, die man bekommen hat, wenn man sich ansatzweise mit englischem Fußball auseinandersetzt.
Aber absolut. Ich dachte ehrlicherweise als Kind ganz lange, dass Sir ein Vorname wäre, ein Englischer. Wegen Sir Bobby Chiton, weil der damals im Kicker immer wieder vorkam auf den internationalen Seiten. Und ich halt jede Seite im Kicker gelesen habe. Und da dachte ich, Sir wäre einfach Vorname. Und dann hießen ja auch andere Sir. Das war für mich Sir Elton John. Da dachte ich mir, ja klar, das ist halt irgendwie so ein Doppelname. Und ich will nicht verraten, wie alt ich war, als ich das verstanden habe. So ist es dann doch nicht. Und das ist meine Verbindung zu Sir Bobby Chiton. Ja, vielen Dank. Das war jetzt auch nochmal ein richtig wichtiger Schwenk. Weil gefühlt ist es schon wieder zwei Wochen her, aber es war ja erst am letzten Wochenende. Weil schon so viele fantastische Texte dazu erschienen sind. Und andere Dinge.
Darf ich da Uli was fragen dazu noch? Und zwar... In der Champions League war es ja erst eine Schweigeminute. Glaubst du, es gibt beim Derby dann einen Minute auf Applaus?
Also die Engländer interpretieren es ja nur mal anders. Ich tippe auch mal. Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt noch nicht. Ich bin noch nicht so weit, aber ich würde tippen, die gesamte Liga macht das. Man sagt ja immer, Minute der Reflektion. Das ist in aller Regel eine Feier des Lebens quasi. Das ist ja auch wesentlich schöner einfach, als zu schweigen. Jetzt kommt ja der Remembrance Month in England. Das heißt, die Zeremonien an die Gedenken der Weltkriegsopfer, die kommen ja jetzt auch an dem Wochenende normalerweise. Das heißt, da gibt es dann sowieso schon mal immer die Mondblumen, dann die Blaskapelle. Also ich weiß nicht, wie man das richtig bezeichnet. Da bin ich raus. Und dann der Marsch, der Einmarsch und so. Und ich würde tippen, dass es dann ziemlich sicher, vielleicht sogar noch gar nicht losgeht an dem Wochenende, auch wenn es Tradition ist, sondern auf jeden Fall Minute des Applauses. Und das wird dann meistens, ja, werden es ja zwei, drei Minuten. Also insbesondere Manchester wird es so sein. Und da freue ich mich irgendwie so. Es klingt komisch, mobile, aber ich freue mich darauf, dass einfach so jemand hochgehalten wird und das Andenken an so jemanden hochgehalten wird.
Ja, ich kann verstehen, auch wenn es jetzt komisch anhört, wie du es gemeint hast gerade. Aber diese Minuten des Applauses sind schon immer sehr ergreifend und haben gleich irgendwie auch was energetischeres als Schweigeminuten, in denen dann irgendein Sufkopf reinschreit, zumindest in deutschen Stadien.
Ja, und gleichzeitig zeigt einem das auch schon so, wie viel man schon mit dem Fußball erlebt hat, finde ich immer wieder. Also ich habe jetzt hier so meine Bobby-Tarten-Geschichte erzählt. Noch ältere Menschen haben ganz, ganz andere Bilder dazu im Kopf. Und das zeigt einem immer, wie viel man auch schon erlebt hat und wie viel man dann doch mit diesem Sport verbindet, trotz all der Probleme, die wir hier ja auch thematisiert haben. Also wenn das jetzt mal nicht eine runde Legatur war, liebe Freundinnen und Freunde da draußen, dann weiß ich es auch nicht. Ihr drei, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlichen Dank an Fabian Pakulat. Danke dir. Mario Rieker, ich werde natürlich alles verlinken, wo man euch folgen kann. Danke dir, Mario. Und herzlichen Dank an Uli Hebel. Und muss nur noch updaten, wo ihr jetzt überall seid, Blue Sky, Mastodon und so weiter. Es ist ja alles so kompliziert geworden. Aber einfach ist geblieben, dass man den Rasenfunk unter rasenfunk.de finden kann. Ich werde in den Show notes verlinken, sowohl den Glücklich Süchtig Podcast als auch das Bügengespräch mit Pina. Und dann danke ich euch für eure Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Unter rasenfunk.de/supportersclubkönnt ihr dem supporters club beitreten und unter kiosk.rasenfunk.de könnt ihr euch Beanie, Foodies und so weiter für den Winter kaufen, wenn ihr möchtet. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit, bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Bleibt gesund, macht's gut, ciao!
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.